colorea el 20% del siguiente cuadrado ok
pero pues para hacer eso primero tenemos
que entender bien qué significa eso del
20% entonces voy a escribirlo por acá
pero con palabras 20 por ciento
entonces ahora lo que realmente nos dice
de qué estamos hablando en esta palabra
es esta primera parte aquí incluso
podemos pensar que está escrito 20 por
cada 100 que 20 por cada
y eso es tal cual lo que significa el 20
por ciento digamos si queremos el 20 por
ciento de este cuadrado grandote lo que
tendríamos que hacer es dividirlo en 100
pedacitos iguales y colorear únicamente
20 cuadraditos nada más que primero
tenemos que saber en cuántos cuadraditos
chiquitos está dividido este cuadrado t
así es que vamos a contar aquí tenemos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez cuadraditos
ocho nueve diez cuadraditos de largo
entonces en total tenemos base por
altura o sea 10 por 10 que es igual a
100 100 cuadraditos chiquitos en total y
si queremos colorear el 20 por ciento
del cuadrado grandote entonces de estos
100 cuadraditos chiquitos pequeños
tenemos que colorear 20 aquí a ver vamos
a empezar coloreando 1
si colocamos este cuadradito lo que
hemos hecho es colorear el 1% del
cuadrado grandote ok porque este
cuadrado lo tenemos dividido en 100
partes iguales y si color hemos una
entonces de cada 100
estamos coloreando una a ver qué pasa si
ahora coloreo dos cuadraditos entonces
qué porcentaje del cuadrado tenemos
coloreado pues tenemos coloreado el 2%
del cuadrado y bueno así coloreo tres
cuadrados como estamos dividiendo al
cuadrado grandote en cien pedazos
iguales entonces hemos coloreado el 3%
del cuadrado así es que pues vamos a
seguir de hecho vamos a colorear toda la
primera fila y bueno en la primera fila
hay uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez de los cien cuadraditos
que dividen al cuadrado grandote
entonces en toda esta fila
hemos coloreado el 10% del cuadrado 'the
pero queremos colorear el 20%
entonces tenemos que colorear otra fila
también aunque vamos a colorear dos
files
y listo este es el 20% del cuadrado